what's the difference between art and
business
boo
well
they have to coexist
I mean even
Michelangelo probably had to make a deal
to paint that ceiling right so it was
interesting lesson that I learned very
early on that's a great question I love
that
because if you don't if if someone who
is an actor or an artist of any sort
doesn't think of themselves as an artist
first
you'll never be an artist you'll be just
be a commodity you'll be some sort of
commoditized version of what you think
you should be
but
business is business and I fell under
the
wing of a brilliant brilliant theater
director named Michael Langham who ran
the Guthrie Theater in Minneapolis and
Stratford and Canada and he directed
John gilgood in the West End I mean he
was a
genius guy and I was very lucky to fall
under his um tutelage for a while
and I looked up to him immensely as this
great artist which he was an incredible
artist he's helped set a standard for me
that I've never forgotten
but one time he he and I were talking
and I don't want to overblow my
relationship to him but we were you know
he he was very kind to me and very uh he
mentored me in in interesting small ways
I got to know his whole family
but he was talking about business and he
said you know he said you owe it to
yourself to go for the money
said you've earned that by all the work
you've put in as an artist at some point
you'll be offered some money
and you owe you owe it to yourself to
take that money because you've earned
that money and that kind of blew my mind
I thought it was really an interest I
didn't think he thought that way I
thought he lived up on a pedestal
somewhere and he didn't I mean he was a
he was a brilliant director but also
knew his business and I think the
difference is understanding that each
has a place and I mean what I don't see
enough of
is people who want to be artists
because it's not really a rewardable
virtue in a way
uh you're really encouraged to be a
commodity
more than an artist and so then you have
a then you have a sell by date
when you're just a commodity you have a
sell-by date you can be an artist for
your whole life it's not easy it's
horribly difficult and challenging but I
think that's the difference but you know
you you do have to have a sense of of
what the business is and what not the
business but business itself and
understanding that I understood that I
think because of how I was raised and my
parents and everything I always had
a very good sense of that and so that
wasn't a lesson I really had to learn
but it's
the hard part was try to be an artist
that's the hard part the business part
was easy for me it always was but to try
to be an artist and to fail at being an
artist much of the time
is the hard part is the challenge you
know I I did a
I did a one-person play about six years
ago
which was the hardest thing I ever did
my wife said why are you doing this are
you driving yourself crazy it was an
hour and a half of me talking
and he was he was also like a 90 year
old Holocaust Survivor and so it was a
whole thing and it was really
challenging I said I'm doing it because
it's there and it's been put in my world
and to not do it would mean I'm not an
artist and I want to see if I can do
that that's a really big mountain to
climb for me I'd never done that I mean
it was so challenging and it ended up
being great it ended up being I was very
happy with the results but it took it
took some time and it took a lot of
effort but it was oh yeah I can do that
yes I have that Within Me
and I think we have to do that from time
to time one of my good friends she's a
wonderful actress herself
uh a little older than me but has had a
great career and she said I can't
believe you did that
I can't first of all I can't believe you
did it number one number two I can't
believe you did it in front of your
students you let your students see it I
said
what do you I said what are you talking
about she said well what if you were bad
and they saw their teacher being bad I
said that never occurred to me that I
would be bad
it just didn't occur to me what no not
going to be bad I'm going to be great
that's the whole point but
so she was coming from a fear-based
thing like oh you shouldn't you
shouldn't uh do this in front of your
students because they look up to you and
if you are mediocre or you're not good
it's I I said uh if that if that thought
entered my mind I would have gotten out
of bed in the morning
so to be an artist is
the highest thing you can do but you do
have to and and I ended up producing
that so I was the businessman too
yeah
would you say auditions callbacks
rehearsals and performances are the art
of acting
um
they're building blocks the art of
acting is in performance I think
I mean I had a the play that I just
referenced
I had one night
it was always good by that one night
where I was like and and
two people were involved with the
production came back said what happened
I said I don't know it was magic it was
magic and I touched it for a second and
I never quite
got that again in that performance I I
did it was great but it wasn't that and
so that's the thing that keeps you it's
like people who play golf
I used to play golf I'm a recovering
golfer but if you hit one great shot in
a round thing like whoa what an
incredible shot it brings you back I'm
gonna play again I gotta play again I
got to do it again and I think acting is
that way when you you know
you're only you're always as good as the
best thing you ever did so I tell that
to people when you're in a down place
and you're not doing well and you're not
feeling good about your work what was
the best thing you ever did
think about that you're still that good
you just haven't accessed it right now
for whatever reason lots of reasons life
gets in the way you know whatever but
you're always that good and that's the
thing you have to hold on to because
uh it just tears you apart it's
heartbreaking for a lot of people
well if something is too easy though
then we lose interest exactly so exactly
there are people who have the gift and
don't know they have the gift and don't
really appreciate
how you know that they have this gift
and and don't nourish the gift
those are rare people who have that
what is the business of acting
the business of acting is
um
sustaining yourself
sustaining yourself in a career
that
allows you to have a life
I think what's happened now
and I think it's it's
um a little bit
reflective of what's happened in our
culture
and our culture will have we now have a
lot of very rich people we have a lot of
very poor people and the middle class
has been a little bit changed
I think the same thing is true in the
acting profession you've got a lot of
people making a lot of money
and you got a lot of people not making
any money and the there used to be and I
was one of them kind of a middle class
or upper upper middle class actor where
you could make a certain amount of money
every year whether you were doing guest
star roles
two three weeks on a movie have a
voiceover campaign you weren't
necessarily a star you didn't get that
show that ran for seven years but you
were in the mix and you were working and
you could make a really good living and
build up your pension which thank
goodness I have now which is wonderful
uh I think that's kind of disappeared
it's much harder the idea of sustaining
yourself
solely as an actor
is kind of gone I hear this from people
who I really love and respect young
people who are working you look at their
resume and you go wow look at all things
you've done they have to bartend they
have to do all this other stuff so you
know for me it was voiceover I I was
very good at voiceover I had a really
good career at it so that was my day job
kind of
and it was great and because it allowed
I made there were times when I made
enough money doing that when I would say
I don't want to do that audition that
for that the stupid show I don't want to
be on it again I'm a snob sometimes and
because I have a little Fu money
okay so because I'm making money doing
that
so you know that was what we now call a
side gig but it was really like a main
part of my career for a long time and it
allowed me to be selective
so the business of it is tricky it's
really tricky and I think being able to
sustain yourself
solely by doing it
is really a challenge much more so than
it used to be
what does an actor need to know right
now about the business of acting
um it depends this it depends another
great question it depends on the stage
that they're in like when you have
people who are
graduating from their BFA program at USC
or UCLA or Carnegie or NYU one of those
places
they don't really they're starting to a
little bit kind of teach about the
business of acting
but I don't think Academia really sees
that as their job
in general they're doing more of it now
than they used to they used to do none
of it
and when I went I taught at USC for a
while and I taught a class about the
actors real
because you realize like your business
card but that's all changed now too
people don't have reels in the same way
that's a different discussion but so I
think what they need to know
are you in it for a cup of coffee or are
you here for dinner
because if you're in it for a cup of
coffee or you're just testing the water
and I tried it for a while it really
wasn't for me
fine go
with God have a good time have a
different life it's fine no one's going
to judge you
but if you're in it for the long haul I
talked to somebody recently who was a
student of mine at USC actually who I
just thinks is amazing
and I asked her are you are you in this
are you in this
absolutely she's in it I said great then
you don't you don't need you just need
some you need to hear yourself say that
and you need to know that that's going
to be a really hard Road
challenging road but it's also brilliant
and exciting and fun it's just
everybody's route to it is different
everybody's you talk to 10 different
people who've been successful at this
they all have excuse me different
circuitous routes that they followed
that there isn't a real
tried and true template for how you
become successful at it but what they
need to know about it is that it's a
business
that it isn't personal
that it is you know your your rejection
is always personal to you
when you are rejected for something it's
personal to you
but it's not personal the casting people
they want you to get that role they
really do they're they're most of the
time they're in your corner they want
you to they want you to solve their
problem their problem is we got to cast
this role we've seen 50 people ah
there's the solution that person just
came into this equation this casting
thing they want that to happen so it's
just a
is understanding that it's a long slog
you know and you need also need to have
somebody
you can't do it alone
you cannot do it alone I have my wife is
incredible and she's been by my side for
decades and I could not have done any of
this without her and so you need a
partner whether it's your best friend
whether it's a wife or husband or
partner you need somebody you need a
community of people that's kind of what
my studio has become for a lot of people
and I think any good acting studio
should be that many of them aren't but I
think it's really important that you
have a group of fellow Travelers who are
trying to all roll the boat in the same
direction and will support each other
when we did our pilot
um we use some studio people and maybe
that's some people we couldn't cast
because it wasn't right for whatever we
had people show up to do extra work you
talked about being background
I know
they were driving out to the middle of
nowhere 100 degree heat just to be a
stand-in because they like what we're
about and and there's a lot of good will
that gets built up and that that is not
lost on me I think you need to have that
community of people and hopefully if
you're lucky a partner or husband or
wife or whatever to help you down the
road and to understand how hard it is
because it's super hard it's it's it's
you know you can't here's the other
thing I've learned about this
you can't discourage people
I'm not in the discouragement business
it does no good
no one could have discouraged me
they could have said oh it's terrible
don't do it do anything else it's
I was not to be discouraged
and so maybe that's a good thing maybe
that's a bad thing but discouraging
people is like spreading a cold
it's nothing good comes from it you know
you can be real with people
and tell them you know what you really
think they should work on what their
chances are that's always a stupid
question you know what are my chances I
don't know I don't know what my chances
are you know so but it's it's just being
real with them about what it is and what
it isn't and if you're after
the commoditized version of yourself and
some people are and some people are
really good at that
you know the influencers instagramers
and they create you know right now
if there's a casting decision between
two people and one has a gigantic
following and one doesn't guess who's
gonna be and it's and it's equal they
can't make a decision
you know I was going to get the part
that's currency now
that's currency and so
do I endorse that not really but you got
to do what you got to do it's more of a
Young Person's game that aspect of it it
was a great comment that someone left on
one of our acting videos and I forget
which one but it was it had me thinking
for a while and he just said and I'm
assuming it's a he
um you know the guy in my class that
studied theater he he had to go to La
and he did and he ended up waiting
tables taking extra work and living in
slum housing that's what he called it
and he's just like like I don't envy him
or whatever
but
it had me thinking just because I get it
but he could have stayed wherever stayed
was he could have gotten a job as an
accountant nothing wrong with it right
great great very important work could
have had a nice home nice cars things
like that would he have been happy
sometimes you just have to take a risk
and and see I say I want to say put
yourself on
kind of a schedule like if you if you
come out to LA and you give it 10 years
it's a long time you give it 10 years
and you're like nowhere
maybe it is time to
redirect your life a little bit or find
something that's ancillary to that that
you actually can do and make a living at
um
I I believe in that I think making your
giving yourself really specific goals
when I came to LA
I didn't know anything I really I mean I
was the theater guy and I was a snob and
all that stuff but I there was a show I
wanted to be on
it was Hill Street Blues I wanted to be
on that show because everybody who was
anybody was on it all the smart people
watched it I said that's what I want and
I made that a goal and I and I got on it
eventually after six or seven auditions
so I always say if you have a specific
goal
you will get a more specific result if
you have a general goal like I just want
to work
no one's interested
I want to work in that I like that show
be really specific and be be be forensic
about understanding okay who cast that
show do I know somebody who knows that
office you got a network it is who you
know by the way absolutely it is who you
know
who you know gets you in the door what
you know may get you the job but it's
important to to network and to be and I
I was never someone I was never really
good at that
because I didn't want to network with
people I didn't like
and I never did kind of
you know I'm happy to network with
people who I think are cool and I like
and I'm sabbatical with and we
understand each other but if they're
just awful
I just couldn't do that that's me but
you know I mean I know some people who
are that's just they are on every red
carpet
and they and they're on every Instagram
post and then you look at their resume
and they haven't really done very much
but they're everywhere
that's a different thing entirely that's
just chasing something for your own
self-aggrandizement right well that's I
was going to ask you said give yourself
a timeline but time goes by very quickly
especially in this town there's a lot of
distractions and so if we're not really
on a path of making things happen we can
trick ourselves into thinking we're
making things happen yes and that's very
easy here in this oh yes little bubble
yeah but set I mean set goals like you
arrive in town and you
your goal is you want to have a really
good Agent within a year
maybe you will maybe you won't it's
really hard to get an agent right now by
the way really hard oh why sorry uh
because
they're all struggling they're all
you know first of all the whole casting
equation has changed it's very much now
about
[Music]
um
ethnic casting is much a much bigger
thing than it was uh you know
multi-ethnic casting and all that and
that's great and that's you know
everyone everyone has their place at the
table but it's just it's just harder
there's more people chasing it it's not
a personal business anymore where you
really meet people
and so you you know if all you're doing
is existing on zoom and meeting people
on Zoom
it's just it's it's just different it's
so it's very impersonal frankly in in my
experience I mean it's different for me
because I've been here so long and I
know a bunch of people and I know
you know I had somebody yesterday wants
some help trying to get an agent or a
manager and I said I'll do it and she's
quite brilliant
and I said I'll do what I can you know
most of the time it's a no
but I do know some people who are really
top at that
and I am happy to I said but I can only
use that bullet once because once I
fired that bullet I can't fire it a
second time but that person so you got
to be ready and all that so that's the
business side of it and it's
it's just I just think there's more
people they say there's more work
but the work is everywhere so like if
there's a show shooting in Atlanta or
New Orleans or New Mexico they shoot a
lot of stuff all over the parts that a
young actor used to get
like a small co-star part in a show
they're going to cast that in Atlanta
where they're not going to fly somebody
in for that so those little building
block parts that actors used to get back
in the day are fewer they're harder to
find or we feel like we have to fill a
racial quota so we have to cast that
part this way or whatever there's lots
of different reasons they all make sense
and they all make sense economically
because it's all about the bottom line
but I just think it's I think it's
exponent it's always been hard I think
it's exponentially harder now in my
opinion